die dichte ist die krise bei ihnen
angekommen in der familie haben wir noch
keinen fall im freundeskreis haben wir
einen fall so positiv getestet mit den
folgen der qualitäten aber noch keine
schlimmen symptomen ich kann nur hoffen
dass das so bleibt aber die ganze
familie macht sich natürlich große
sorgen um mama bosbach die mit großen
schritten auf den 92 geburtstag zugeht
und wir besuchen die mutter regelmäßig
aber jetzt müssen wir leider abstand
halten und ich hoffe doch dass wir bald
wieder zum gewohnten umgang miteinander
umgehen können aber im moment hat eben
den schutz der alten damit ihre oberste
priorität denn wenn man ein so hohes
alter erreicht hat dann kann die
infektion dramatische folgen haben und
deswegen kann ich nur hoffen dass meine
mama davon verschont bleibt und wir tun
alles damit sie sich nicht an steckt man
liegt der geburtstag an wird steht er an
im juli